one of the classic definitions of
mindfulness is that it helps us not
cling to what's pleasant and not condemn
what is unpleasant an example would be
if you're driving in New York City and
someone cuts you off you know that's
unpleasant and one would instinctively
have an angry response but that's
happening all the time and if you have
an angry response too often then you
become a nightmare yourself so what
mindfulness is teaching is that the
stimulus which is someone cutting you
off is different it's distinct from your
emotional reaction to that thing so
someone could cut you off you could feel
the anger but you don't have to act on
the anger so instead of being driven by
your reactions there's a little bit of a
room where you can choose to be a
different kind of person so mindfulness
basically helps us tolerate the the
aspects of the external world and the
internal world that otherwise are hard
to face
there are basically two kinds of
meditation it one which is a
concentration practice you focus your
attention on a neutral sensation like
the feeling of the breath coming in and
out of the nostrils or like the
repetition of a sound or what's called a
mantra and every time the mind wanders
whenever you notice that it's wandered
that might be five minutes ten minutes
later when you're lost in thought but at
a certain point you realize oh wait I'm
not watching the breath anymore
then you bring your mind back to the
breath that's called a concentration or
a one-pointed practice and that's the
that's the beginning level of
mindfulness when you really start
practicing mindfulness instead of
bringing the mind back every time to a
central object you let the attention go
wherever the mind goes so instead of
paying attention just to the breath or
the mantra you pay attention to sounds
you pay attention to thoughts you pay
attention to feelings you pay attention
to memories you pay attention to worries
to anxieties to anger to joy you pay
attention to whatever passes through
your mind moment to moment and then what
you start to see is that oh everything
is changing all the time and you learn
to pay attention more to process than to
content
it's really only in the past 5060 years
that the medical establishment has been
exposed at all to what mindfulness is
and for 20 30 of those years it was like
just a new age thing it was on the
periphery and only through the work of a
couple of people like Jon kabat-zinn has
mindfulness come in to the medical
establishment there are a lot of studies
that are being done now that are showing
the benefit of mindfulness for all kinds
of conditions and some old colleagues of
mine have done some very good work
showing that the steady practice of
mindfulness light up areas of the brain
that have to do with modulating
emotional reactivity so I think there's
beginning evidence that the the brain is
plastic more plastic than we initially
thought and that the you know what what
you feed into the brain actually changes
the architecture of the brain so that
it's possible to promote to develop the
areas of the brain that are there for
kindness you know for altruistic feeling
and for the regulation of difficult
emotions